[музика]
я Сергій Зінченко проведено інженер
центру розробленої експлуатації ліній
проти компанії майча 9 Роккі Я народився
у Київській області
ділянки
центр ремонту експлуатації вже майже 40
років
з Росії
ми просуємо для того, щоб людей було
світло
на природі весь час Це вже добре
тут все навіть ніби загартовані тому
що витримали по морозу працюють
[музика]
ой сечі
наша робота своєю робота з pedition
basecoyo крім тих обстріляти ті або
інші речі напруга Ну я кааса чекай я коїни
Майамі Запаха не кольору нічого і люди
завжди в душі близько білени і цедру
дружини без печна щоранку ми не
приходимо На роботу ми не знаємо куди ми
зараз поїдемо раніше у нас були план
планування завжди є Ну 50 відсотків
у нас зараз план якось не сильно
спрацьовує тому що там приліт там
ще там падіння там аварія там слідство
тих ще перших обстрілів коли тільки
вона була не близько були перебиті
дроти Вони повністю не відремонтовані
були
клими грунту протити на майданчик
Квітні акули росіян у вигляді шви
ніхто ж там не знав що такі там
снарядних тоніколи його не бачи там ось
ці гармати титанки коли тільки почало
було Війни коли тут Вони стояли під
вишневим бомбардували і там із міст побили
нам таку приблизно лінію
так опору навпіл вона була ми тільки
замінили її там панам знову стріляли ми
там усі стрибали добре ховалися
і потім приліт був буквально двох пар
тижнів на цю ж лінію Тільки не в тому
ліси трохи далі також відновлювали
вночі коли тільки підійшли росіяни до
під бучу під Гостомель під мощун
практично всі лінії були ці
перебиті дроти тому що снарядами
йшли бої багато пошкоджень і ми можна
сказати все літо та весну відновлювали
після цих ушкоджень
не було б прильоту до цих поетів було б
простіше до цього ми жили якось
більш-менш не було з відключення
коли до жовтня до було складність там
але потім відновлювали і ушкоджень
тобто ці теж 100 мільйонів уже
ніколи не вимикався не не буде
завжди було енергія там світло було а
ось як почалися вже з енергооб'єктом
бити
була схожа на двох олова високовольтна
лінія та Повністю
Вся чорна каже трансформаторне
олія шкіряна платна
ми по людині свої роботи тут о 10
вечора Темрява нам треба було зараз там
чотири води щоб
шкіряні мінімально працюючи яка була
забути Щоб заживити їх 53 тисячі
склалася
[музика]
виїзд Усі туди терміново грузилися Ну
бачите що машина сильно це все було
завантажено матеріалами працювали по
20-30 годин на день правда волонтери нам
трохи допомагали там годували гарячими
образами звичайно міг бути в цей момент
повторний прильоти Це був ризик містечко
був без світла без тепла всі там молилися
на нас Коли ми це відновимо ми це
відчували цю відповідальність ніхто не
нарікав Ніхто не говорив що мені час до
вдома ми відновлювали ці лінії
за два дні відновили цю лінію першу
частина потім уже простіше небагато
передача електроенергії
вирівнюється електроенергія просто
проблема і перерозподілить і доставить до
кінця вас побажати скіке прибуватиме
там гармата ми будемо благодать лагудити
ще розкладати обладнання все менше і
менше стає дроти Ми
відновлюємо у нас є по
підстанціям трохи складніше тому
зараз начебто закуповується за кордони
привозиться але вона не сильно до наших
підходять Ну якось переробляють на
нашої лінії на наші
під нашу мережу
на нас поблажок ні включає нас також
як і вас та інших за якимось графіком
Хоча він не завжди дотримується
дотримується
десь пошкодження енергооб'єктів усі
тому що нестача потужності треба
відрубувати бо посипатися
трансформатори почнуть горіти, як хочеться
війна Це буквально
місяць-два і все буде. Зараз не дають
відновити і як вона не увійде до цього
постійно збій постійно ось цей
кработор пити і знову ж таки TLC Ну постривай
не вигляд ключниці теж робота там садять
Живі люди відчують і китиш
мою право на полицю та
графіки є і в принципі ми намагаємося
їх до ранку
колись доїхали один раз уже вночі
відновлювати щось нас пропускали і
вранці щось встановили там частину тепла
з'явилася там у місті то нам навіть
сигналили спасибі було і таке буває
там формі Варта і вся Ну дому і там
людочки по Доброго дня я у вас там
справи нібито там усі не протили вже
так би мовити людей
навіть у монеті грубо кажучи пляшку Так я
живу Хто сьогодні тобто там зуби лікувати
тобто там пологи Приймаючи а тобто
ремонту я проводи та трансформатори
Я вважаю, що всі ми герої ми родом на
свою роботу